[Music]  turning trash into eco-friendly coal  Cameroon has a big waste problem the  streets are strewn with piles of  household waste maintenance workers are  struggling to deal with it  but now there's a solution students are  turning waste into eco-friendly coal  they collect organic rubbish from the  streets then shred and dry it and  finally turn it into organic coal in an  oven the students project produces 15  tons per month the Eco coal meets demand  for cheap energy they already have over  400 clients Cameroon faces a huge  deforestation problem the burning of  charcoal threatens mangrove forests  their eco coal could help it's even  cheaper than charcoal or firewood  [Music]  if you are also doing your bit tell us  about it visit our website or send us a  tweet hashtag doing your bit we share  your stories  [Music]